we lost Mary Tyler Moore recently and I
know that she was a huge part of your
life and I was just curious if you had
an insight into what made her I mean you
really discovered her well what do you
think made her special what made her so
different well first of all an
extraordinary talent
I mean her talent was she was a dancer
as a young girl and dancers if they can
do anything if they can dance and try
anything else they usually are the best
of it they're saying when she came and I
had seen 23 girls looking for a girl to
play Laura Petry and I remember telling
Sheldon executive deuce I said I don't
know I'm looking for he's you don't know
when you'll find it yeah and one day
this girl comes to my I had seen 23 she
comes in and she was reluctant coming
because she had failed in two auditions
that week and she sort of was she told
me she didn't feel like coming in and
soon as she walked in I looked at her
face and I gave her a piece of paper to
read a line she read one word I said
hold it it was what I called a ping in a
voice there was something of then I
looked at her with those eyes the lips
the smile those gams yeah I mean she was
just so very beautiful hi my hand became
a claw the kind that in the you you know
when the arcades the grab the candy and
I remember walking across the room when
I said with my hand above her and I
grabbed the top of her head and I said
come with me young lady
yeah you get in trouble for that kind of
thing now I thought of that then I said
done that on the street it doesn't go
well right and I walked down the hall to
Sheldon Linda's office and I dropped the
like you know candy I said we found her
yeah well she could do it obviously she
could do it all one of the most iconic
scenes I remember from the Dick Van Dyke
Show and I thought maybe we could just
show it because you're here and it's a
special thing
that it was the scene where she has
mistakenly by mistake she outed her
husband's boss you know she outed you as
being bald yes and you're this famous
entertainer and no one's supposed to
know that you're bald and she has maybe
jeopardized your career you're furious
and she has to come in and apologize
yeah right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you and you see a clip like that are you
able to connect to that time are you
able to order is it just the way the
rest of us see it meaning the rest of us
see a great episode of the Dick Van Dyke
Show or do you connect to yes I remember
that day I remember there's the most
important thing about that day for the
first when I started the show I had
written 13 episodes and the for the
first two years I was its producer its
writer and his story editor I was all
alone nobody there and I did like 50 out
of the 40 60 shows all written by myself
and I was going to die and these two
guys Phil Percy and Sam Dennis was
partly came in and wrote this show they
brought it in I read it and I said this
one of the best shows I've ever written
they said I tell I tell I tell Billy all
the time you saved my life yeah I would
have been dead right and they became
writers on the show we wrote together
and in the final year they became
producer for the last 12 shows when I
did the Russians are coming they jump
over know that particular show means so
much to me
you